[Music]
hello I'm wiki bear what's your name
Conan O'Brien Conan Christopher O'Brien
American talk show host in two-time host
of the Emmys oh cool I'm surprised you
knew that I can answer it in question
you have I'm Winky bear
all right now Twix II bear what's the
only pop song to ever hit number one on
the charts two different times check now
[Music]
you're thinking of the twist by Chubby
Checker it was number one in 1960 then
again in 62 the song was so catchy it's
what people today would call an earworm
oh that's absolutely right that's cool
you know one worm you wooden one your
ear is the filarial worm it's a parasite
that attacks your lymphatic system and
can cause massive swelling including
elephantitis of the genitals yeah okay
Ricky boy that's cool but no kids don't
want to talk about that that's all but
they should imagine the humiliation of
people constantly pointing at your
scrotum and accusing you of shoplifting
to Butterball turkey yeah okay come back
here Turkey thing yeah no no no no no no
one no one wants to think about that
Wicky bear but on the plus side with
beanbag sized testicles you'll always
have a comfortable place to sit I break
it okay let's change the subject Koppel
squad kids oh shut up let's change the
subject what's the name of the furry
little creature that befriends the baby
elephant in the Walt Disney cartoon
Dumbo there would be Timothy Q Mouse who
helped Dumbo learn how to fly whoa yeah
okay that is absolutely right
you know who else tried to teach a bunch
of dumb bows to fly the leader of the
Heaven's Gate religious cult
who told his followers that they could
all fly away from Earth on a spaceship
by committing mass suicide
oh yeah religion okay now depressing
that's depressing when the police found
their bodies they were all wearing
matching black t-shirts and brand new
Nike basketball shoes
kudos to Nike and great product
placement Nike was not happy about that
I'm sure so remember kids if you're
thinking of joining an apocalyptic cult
follow Nikes advice and just we really
need to find something more appropriate
for kids how about this okay this is
nice
what's the name of the collectible toy
cars manufactured by Mattel Hot Wheels
yep they were called how wheels yes
first introduced in 1968 these tiny
hotrod soon became even more popular
than their competitor Matchbox cars okay
that's right and I'd forgotten all about
that that's cool speaking of hot rods
are you familiar with Meccano philia the
sexual fetish for people who are
sexually attracted to machines like cars
and vices no I don't know about that and
I do not want to know about that it's
all true one McKenna feely AK an
American gentleman named Edward Smith
claimed to have had sex with over 1,000
cars talk about blowing some gaskets
all right that's it look that's fine you
know Conan I'm technically a machine in
case anyone out there wants to give me a
chart here's a tip I only take size D
batteries and by D batteries I mean huge
penis for God's sake
now we're good now we're good
you